welcome everybody i want to start today
off and start the week off with
something we really haven't done in
about um in about six weeks which is
just kind of go over what's going on
with kovid because things have changed
pretty dramatically over the last six
weeks
we've not done the weekly covet updates
that at one point we were doing my
thought was
first of all with so much else going on
there's no shortage of things to talk
about but also let's really give this
omicron wave
four to six weeks to burn through and
see where we are once we close in on
mid-february and for the most part in
the united states things are looking so
much better
that there are now
what i would call serious discussions
about moving into the endemic phase
whereas before there was a lot of kind
of hear no evil see no evil let's just
go back to pretending everything is
normal things are not normal now but the
discussions about next steps make a lot
more sense and as i've said before
before we look at the numbers
if there is not
a more deadly
new variant
um
there is sort of nothing else to wait
for before we figure out what will what
will things be like with this as an
endemic thing now endemic doesn't
necessarily mean no risk and to many
people it still means a risk but the
question is sort of if not now when
because if we are moving into an endemic
phase with no
really serious new variant for one year
two years three years
what are we going to do over those one
two or three years if not now what would
be different in two years if the
situation remains sort of as it is now
now one caveat to that is even though
cases are dropping dramatically as i
will soon show you
it's going to take some time for the
hospitals to empty out we are still
seeing
hospitals quite full right now
because of the waves peak now many weeks
ago
and it will take some time for that to
abate assuming there's no new really
contagious and or deadly variant but
let's look at where we are right now if
you look at the united states
daily cases are now down from an insane
peak of 800 000 cases a day
all the way down to 239 000. now that's
still a lot it puts us sort of at the
delta peak but with a variant with
significantly lower rate of
hospitalization rate remember
that's down about
through almost almost three quarters you
look at some individual states you look
at new york new york peaked at seventy
five thousand cases a day and is down to
about eight thousand you know almost a
ninety ninety percent reduction you look
at massachusetts massachusetts peaked at
about twenty four thousand cases a day
down all the way down to 3 000 okay
that's a you know massive massive
reduction even places like texas
seeing a reduction only about 50 percent
but still going
in the downward direction and then when
you look globally globally the decline
is earlier we are earlier in the decline
we had gotten to 3.3 million global
cases a day now down to 2.7 million so
there are parts of the world that are
nowhere near
doing well as we would say
and we will talk about some of those in
a moment but
the important thing for our purposes
is that we are seeing
countries states school districts start
to talk about
what are the next steps now in terms of
vaccinating kids
under five there's the hope i mean i
think that the most optimistic
prediction is by march that may start
it's plausible it's not going to be
march and it could be april maybe or or
maybe even may
but you were starting to see a lot of
places make decisions about travel for
example australia which has been one of
the tightest strictest places since the
start of the pandemic will be reopening
borders to international travel as
reported by the bbc
that's from uh this morning so australia
starting to open there are a number of
additional european countries that are
moving towards what we might call an
exit from the pandemic italy switzerland
and finland are going to be easing
restrictions and guidelines germany and
belgium so far
are not
but many other countries denmark and
others going back to
normal as we might say
still of course with the caveat that
there are going to be people who are
going to continue
doing whatever they've been doing and
one of the interesting things that we've
talked about before is
there's this discussion of when can we
treat this like flu
one answer to make it an empirical
answer and not an emotional answer one
answer would be when the death rate
matches that of flu that that would be
something to look at
it is hypothesized that the omicron
overall death rate is about 0.2 percent
flu is 0.15 so we're not there yet
but it's going in that direction one
additional caveat to that is
the death rate for the vaccinated is
significantly lower than the 0.2 percent
the death rate for the unvaccinated is
significantly higher so
what you can safely
uh
the the framework that you can
accurately assess for yourself does
depend significantly on whether you are
or aren't vaccinated but one of those
questions is well when the death rate
becomes that of the flu
it would make sense to go back to normal
right well no the reality is that these
two years have exposed for a lot of
people i wasn't as safe as i thought
during flu season and there are
absolutely people who
used to not take any precautions
um when flu was rampant during flu
season but even if and when coveted risk
goes back down to match flu it will
still feel more dangerous and that
people will be more aware of that risk
and they may continue to take
precautions and of course everybody
should do exactly what makes sense for
them in conversation with doctors and
based on their their risk assessment but
that's the the conversation that's
happening south korea
as reported by the korea herald pushes
to treat covet 19 like flu
they have lots of cases but low severity
relatively low hospitalizations relative
quite quite a low death rate so that's
the south korean perspective
um in new jersey the governor will be
ending the school mass mandate next
month in march and there are many
municipalities i saw some in uh and by
the way there are places that never did
anything it's like i'm not even talking
or thinking about those i'm talking
about places that did stuff
are now having conversations there's
some municipalities in massachusetts
that are moving away from the masks some
in new york a number of different places
caveat things are still not good in a
lot of places russia has hit a new
record they currently have 10 times more
cases than a month ago to the extent
that we can believe the russian data it
is now 10 times higher cases than a
month ago that's not good for them
um hong kong is bracing for more
uh curbs or or guidelines mandates as
cases are doubling every three days very
complicated situation in hong kong
china is locking down bayes city on the
vietnam border as cases are continuing
to go up still low numbers and of course
china has taken a sort of at least
officially a zero covet approach now
whether that's zero covet or zero
covered reporting you know that there's
debate about that but there are
significant lockdowns happening there as
well so what can we do well i think
again the question is
reminder we've been here before
what is different now
the difference is
there is more support for the discussion
now about moving into the endemic phase
in terms of public opinion than there
ever was before but there's also more
support from medical experts we spoke to
vincent raqueniello two weeks ago
we've read the the opinions of many
other public health experts and
if things change it will require a
different approach but if we are going
in this direction
then there is this question of what are
the milestones we are waiting for and
there are people who are going to keep
themselves in a sort of purgatory for a
very long time that's the reality and
every individual has to balance
you know the the their their risk
tolerance their health situation and the
mental health impact uh that is that is
undeniable uh i mean you know the right
is not wrong when they say there is a
mental health impact of doing this it's
a question of when does the balance
shift
and the answer is different for
everybody
so we're going to continue monitoring
all of these decisions
and seeing
if the downtrend continues which if it
does
within another two weeks we could we
could be 95 to 97 percent down in terms
of daily cases
and when you have that combined with the
effectiveness of vaccines at preventing
death you really have a dramatically
different situation to consider
in terms of what every individual wants
to be doing
hey i have something unbelievable for
you
last week in the morning friday morning
fox news was gleefully gleefully
predicting a disastrous jobs report they
were doing coverage all morning it's
going to be terrible it's going to be
terrible they were rooting for our
failure
which they say we do which of course we
don't they were they were rooting
against america
and then the jobs report came in
and it was fantastic it was it was an
incredible jobs report that we actually
had us added over 450 000 jobs in
january 2022 strong demand at
restaurants retailers mail and parcel
delivery leisure and hospitality added
more than 150 000 jobs
retail added 61 000 i mean just
incredible numbers
and fox had to then just go silent
you have to see this here is the morning
on fox
before the jobs report and the next hour
the january job report will be released
and it could be the worst in years the
white house has been bracing for a bad
number it could be a loss of 300 000
jobs how's the white house going to put
a happy face on that
the real question is how are you going
to put a sad face on the incredible
numbers we got he thinks that we might
see a loss of hundreds of thousands of
jobs it could be a morning of pain
because just about 28 minutes from right
now the january jobs report is going to
be released by the bureau of labor and
whatnot projection is for an already low
150 000 jobs added but adp the company
that processes payrolls says to expect
301 000 jobs lost that would be a half a
million jobs swing the wrong way the
biden administration bracing for yet
another economic bus we're gonna bring
you the january jobs report soon after
well it didn't work out that way the
january jobs report just released the
u.s adding
sixty 467 thousand jobs left so they
they did ultimately report on the
numbers
and many of these people going
completely and totally silent
uh some funny uh one funny graphic that
they had was this like completely
uh
negative catastrophic more job losses
and huge red font february 4th 2022
and of course it didn't happen now you
can always ask questions like well what
is the quality of these jobs uh what are
the wages of the these we always ask
these questions this is not a partisan
thing for me
when
i was the first to tell you during the
trump administration the economy was
mostly doing very well whether it had
anything to do with trump was a real
question whether these jobs numbers have
anything to do with biden is a
completely fair question but the rooting
against america which i always thought
they said we did
even though they do it is just another
instance of projection and this is
completely beyond parody this is later
on
steve ducey asking stuart varney how did
everybody get it so wrong all right the
january jobs report is in white house
should be happy about that steve over to
you all right thank you very much carly
let's bring in stuart barney host of
barney and company and american built on
fox business stuart you know this
morning we were projecting what uh one
estimate was 150 000 or it could have
been 300 000 in the hole right it's
close to half a million how did
everybody get this so wrong well you're
right everybody did get this chronically
wrong i'm not sure i can really explain
why we've got this explosion of 467 000
jobs because it does run counter to what
we were expecting we thought that covid
or omicron in particular would be
keeping millions of people at home they
would not be at work and that would be
jobs lost now what's funny is they
didn't originally think that like they
downplayed omicron they downplayed
reports from fouchy and others we could
have fifteen twenty percent of the
population out sick
but now they're saying no i mean based
on all that stuff which we rejected for
weeks we were expecting it to be bad
well it didn't work out that way i'm
sure that millions of people are at home
suffering from omicron and this these
figures were taken in january but the
overall number was still way up there i
can explain one thing here the
unemployment rate went up from 3.9 to 4
it went up right now that so
that actually isn't necessarily a bad
thing now i i we've talked about and
again you
fact check me go back and look at how i
cover jobs okay it it's not a partisan
thing for me
sometimes the unemployment rate goes up
because more people are starting to look
for jobs when you are actively looking
for a job you are considered unemployed
if you stop looking you are no longer
considered unemployed this was the case
under reagan under cl this is just this
is what it is and i don't play these
games where i ignore how these things
are measured depending on who's in the
white house i don't care about political
party
but sometimes
when the economy is getting better more
people say i now want to re-enter the
workforce and they become considered
actively unemployed so it doesn't tell
us much that the unemployment rate went
from i think 3.9 to 4.0 um it and and uh
we're gonna continue covering this in
the same
empirical way that we've been from the
beginning but how sad they were over at
fox
that the jobs report was good
let me know your thoughts you can find
me on twitter at dpakman and we'll be
right back
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount joinpakman.com
the david pakman show is sponsored
directly by viewers and listeners who
sign up at join joinpackman.com we do an
extra show every single day for our
members called the bonus show remember
that alex jones hates the bonus show oh
the bonus show where you want to make
money everybody else that makes money to
find themselves is bad i can think of no
greater endorsement for the world famous
bonus show than alex jones being against
it thank your lucky stars every day
you're not dave pacman you can sign up
at
isn't it crazy that this is my job you
can sign up at joinpakman.com and use
the coupon code wow 22.
i have for you today
one of the craziest political stories
that i have ever covered and it might
not seem that crazy because it has been
slowly building
but former vice president mike pence has
now turned on donald trump publicly in a
speech at the federalist society in
florida over the weekend
and donald trump has reacted by
completely losing it on mike pence it is
not normal
that a former president and vice
president just 13 months after leaving
office are in such public conflict mike
pence publicly now has said
that uh he had no ability or right to
overturn the results of the 2020
election and trump doesn't like that
because trump wanted pence to steal the
election this is part of the growing
civil war in the republican party and
let me tell you clearly and directly
this is not normal it is not normal for
a president and a vice president to have
such major public disagreement so
quickly after leaving office and it is
not over something minor
this is something major the ex-president
says he won
and the vice president could have
flipped the results the ex-vice
president says we didn't win and i have
no right to change the results this is a
disagreement as big as anybody could
imagine dealing with the most
fundamental and crucial elements of how
our democracy is supposed to work let's
go to the clip here is mike pence
president trump said i had the right to
overturn the election
but president trump is wrong
i had no right to overturn the election
the presidency belongs to the american
people true and the american people
alone
and frankly there is no idea more on
american
than the notion that any one person
could choose the american president
under the constitution i had no right to
change the outcome of our election
and kamala harris will have no right
to overturn the election when we beat
them in 2024.
all right well listen maybe maybe but
pence is correct in what he is saying
there and donald trump very quickly
completely triggered putting out a
statement saying quote just saw mike
pence's statement on the fact that he
had no right to do anything with respect
to the electoral vote count other than
being an automatic conveyor belt for the
old crow mitch mcconnell to get biden
elected president as quickly as possible
that was one sentence well the vice
president's position is not an automatic
conveyor if obvious signs of voter fraud
or irregularities exist
that's why the democrats and rhinos are
working feverishly
interesting i would describe this
statement as febrile interesting that
trump uses the word feverishly working
feverishly together to change the very
law that mike pence and his unwitting
advisors used on january 6 to say he had
no choice the reason they want it
changed is because they now say they
don't want the vice president to have
the right to ensure an honest vote in
other words i was right and everyone
knows it now of course that's not true
the truth about that is
pre-trump there was no disagreement as
to the vice president's ability to to
flip an election
because it even came up in 2020
and the former the now former then
almost former president was pushing
pence to do this there is a move to
strengthen the language to make it even
more clear
but the vice president does not have the
opportunity or ability to change
election results trump lastly says if in
other words i was right and everyone
knows it if there is fraud or
large-scale irregularities it would have
been appropriate to send those votes
back to the legislatures to figure it
out the dems and rhinos want to take
that right away a great opportunity lost
but not forever in the meantime our
country is going to hell
folks this is not normal this this
really is kind of like an end of days
type situation which hopefully just
won't actually lead to the end of days
that's that's that's the hope that this
is just okay yeah this is crazy but he's
out of power and he's not going to be
back in power that's the optimistic
scenario now it's very important to
mention at this point
it seems abundantly clear that if trump
does run in 2024 and wins the nomination
his running mate is not going to be mike
pence i can only imagine who it would be
that would be an interesting choice and
i would assume
it would be someone even more radical
than pence now i think there's an
important
disclaimer to make here
as far as pence being the good guy
this is too little too late it has been
13 months since the attempted
insurrection
he was just doing his job and what i
mean by that is
he can't overturn the election it was
crazy that trump even tried to get him
to attempt it pence caused a ton of
damage during his reign as vice
president he said almost nothing about
this until now he doesn't get a medal
pence is horribly toxic he couldn't
overturn the election he didn't choose
not to overturn it he couldn't overturn
it all he's saying now is it's true
i couldn't overturn it imagine not
killing someone in january of 2021 after
your friend urges you your friend goes
please kill this person you don't do it
and then in february of 22
you go i was right not to kill anybody
right murder's illegal you don't get a
cookie for reminding us that 13 months
later uh 13 months later that 13 months
ago you did the only thing you could do
you couldn't overturn the election and
you didn't you don't get a cookie for
that now what's the upside here the
upside is what we're soon going to
discuss
which is that this rift between pence
and trump adds to the republican
fragmentation here's an example here is
uh former trump propaganda stephen
bannon
uh attacking pence over this
pence you're gonna cut you're gonna
carry this thing uh eventually to your
grave okay
because
it is a mark of shame and you are a
stone cold coward a stone cold coward
for a sepsis we're going to start with
numbers and analysis yeah so
pence could have done nothing else the
the only thing
the only thing pence could do
was
not try to overturn the election because
he does not have the right or the power
to overturn the election it was the law
it was the constitution but it's
furthering the rift within the
republican party
and i argue that that is a very good
thing
let's talk about that
i'm really glad that something i've been
saying for a couple of months now is
getting more attention it's not getting
more attention from me saying it to be
clear what i mean is i'm glad other
people are coming to the same conclusion
which is that by all accounts
republicans should do very well in the
upcoming midterms now and we're under
six under nine months away from the
midterms one of the best chances at
republicans not doing well
is the explosion of the internal
disagreements and civil war that we're
increasingly seeing within the
republican party which we have been
covering
david seiders and natalie allison wrote
about this in a piece for politico
called trump's circular firing squad
threatens republican midterm gains
and this outlines a lot of what we've
been saying
and the article says
nine months before the midterms nearly
everything is falling the republican
party's way from joe biden's dismal
approval ratings to rising gas prices
and a seemingly never-ending pandemic
yet as the rnc concluded its winter
meeting here on friday it was censuring
two of its own uh representatives liz
cheney and adam kinzinger and decrying
the house's january 6 select committee
for what ronna mcdaniel the rnc chair
called the quote persecution of ordinary
citizens who engaged in legitimate
political discourse that had nothing to
do with violence at the capitol in a
year in which even many democrats
acknowledge the republicans will likely
win the house and despite republican
lawmakers and strategists pleading with
republicans to keep their focus on
pocket book issues and on biden the rnc
is still recasting the events of january
6th and chasing down enemies of the
defeated former president donald trump
they go on to say
for all the energy he creates at the
party's grassroots his stranglehold on
the party is emerging as one of the
biggest threats to the republicans
otherwise bright prospects in november
he has singled out ten house republicans
for extinction he's attacking republican
governors backing primary challengers
meddling in senate races where it may
lead to the nomination of flawed
candidates ill-suited for a general
election he's fomenting rebellion
against the party senate leader mitch
mcconnell and this week in salt lake
city it was david bossie the former
trump deputy campaign manager leading
the effort to kick cheney and kinzinger
to the curb read the entire article but
it gets to the really key point which is
a sad point
for us right i care about the left
the left is really failing right now
it it's just really failing in terms of
setting itself up to do well nine months
from now in the midterms
sadly like it it it really pains me to
admit this but the person best position
to save the country from trumpian
insanity is trump and trumpists
sabotaging their own midterms it's
tragically sad that this is the case for
the democratic party right now but with
under nine months
to go until the midterms i'll take any
help i can get and so when we see trump
doing this insane stuff we see
republicans censuring adam kinzinger and
liz cheney last week i told you that
george w bush from another wing of the
republican party has donated the maximum
allowed by law
to both lisa murkowski and liz cheney
two people two republicans that
supported the impeachment of donald
trump
i will take all of it
because they're all terrible remember
liz cheney is not our friend liz cheney
when the rubber met the road voted with
trump most of the time so it's all bad
we're
maybe i mean listen are we even better
off
with a non-trump republican than a trump
republican if the non-trump republican
is slightly less crazy but more likely
to get their policies passed we're
poorly off no matter what
so i would love to see the democratic
party get it together um and take
advantage of this situation where for
you know historically looking it should
not be a great midterm for democrats but
maybe it could be
this is the biggest gift we could
imagine and so we have to do everything
we can to encourage the civil war to
continue we'll have more on this on our
instagram page which you can find at
david pakman show
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com
david pakman show one of the biggest
flash points in the 2016 presidential
election came around records
records retention
emails email servers
responsibility
with classified and sensitive
information all directed
at hillary clinton remember that this
was
the biggest storyline about hillary
clinton she would be in jail trump said
if i was president because of what she
did with emails and documents and so on
and so forth
every day now i'm not exaggerating every
day just over the weekend each day there
was another major story about the trump
white house and records and we have
we're going to look at two of those
stories now and the first is that
essentially a raid took place on
mar-a-lago
where the national archives showed up
to get trump's documents
many of which related to meetings with
north korean dictator kim jong-un
remember those love letters remember
trump said and we fell in love
trump did not turn over the records
to the national archives he took him to
mar-a-lago and the national archives had
to go down there and get the records
this is an incredible story uh
washington post reporters
jacqueline alemany josh dossey and
others
reporting president trump improperly
removed multiple boxes from the white
house that were retrieved by the
national archives last month from his
mar-a-lago residents he just took the
documents home
because they contained documents and
other items that should have been turned
over to the agency according to three
people familiar with a visit
the recovery of the boxes from trump's
florida resort raises new concerns about
his adherence to the presidential
records act which requires the
preservation of memos letters notes
emails faxes and other written
communications related to a president's
official duties trump advisors deny any
nefarious intent of course and say the
boxes contain mementos gifts
letters from world leaders
who could not realize
that those are presidential records and
other correspondence the items included
correspondence with north korean leader
kim jong-un which trump once described
as love letters and then we fell in love
right
right
as well as a letter left for his
successor by president barack obama
according to two people familiar with
the contents discussions between the
archives and the former president's
lawyers that began last year resulted in
the transfer of the records in january
another person familiar with the
materials said trump advisors discussed
what had to be returned in december
people familiar with the transfer spoke
on the condition of anonymity so in
december they explained to trump what
needed to be returned
and uh it took
uh the national archives showing up
later to actually get the stuff
the archives have struggled to cope with
the president who flouted there it is
guys see i told you it's a real word
people always say when i say flouted
david don't you mean flaunt it and i say
no i mean flouted a president who
flouted document retention requirements
and frequently ripped up official
documents leaving hundreds of pages
taped back together so
um
this is uh
this story and we're going to talk about
the incineration of documents in a
moment
this is the prototypical backwards
projection scam that was this entire
presidency the story in 2016 was
hillary's gonna do bad stuff with
records hillary can't be trusted with
email
uh documents classified secret sensitive
and since trump has left
we found out that the real concern
around all of those things was donald
trump and his kids and other people that
worked for him do we think hillary would
have eaten documents as donald trump
allegedly did no do we think hillary
would have ripped documents and tossed
them onto the floor and then people run
in and grab the scraps and tape them
back together of course not do we think
hillary would have taken documents about
foreign policy meetings and letters from
foreign leaders to her house
give me a break guys and we can argue
about anything else about hillary versus
trump that's fine
but on this issue which was the
flashpoint about why hillary can't be
trusted
trump's the guy that we need to worry
about
uh i would love to hear more about the
retrieval that took place
and this is not the only story about
trump and white house records that we
have today the next story relates to
incineration
so let me reset a little bit
um
we
talked last week
about this report
that trump white house staffers
regularly
had to
tape back together
um
things that donald trump would rip up
we now have more news about this trump
white house white house staffers
frequently put important documents into
burn bags
and sent them to the pentagon
to be incinerated so you've got
conflicting teams you've got one team
that understands presidential records
act and preservation of records when
trump rips stuff up and tosses it they
run in and tape it back together
it's like you know reminded of the movie
a beautiful mind
um
some of you will get that reference and
then at the same time you've got another
team
that is
collecting records and sending them to
be incinerated
trump era white house staffers
frequently put documents in burn bags
regular burn runs would see these bags
taken to the pentagon for incineration
this is per the washington post it was
up to the staffers to decide which
documents to preserve and which to
destroy
it has been widely reported that trump
had a penchant for tearing apart
presidential documents but details have
emerged about how aids disposed of
potentially important papers
burn bags resemble paper grocery bags
and are widely available at the white
house organizations dealing with top
secret info like the cia and nsa often
use them because destruction via burn
bags is considered superior to shredding
that's true you can sometimes tape
together stuff that's been shred
shredded uh you typically you want to
use a cross cut shredder instead of the
one that just generates strips but it's
crazy what the kids these days can do so
you burn it of course it appears that it
was done with documents that are
supposed to be preserved
this was a disaster it was almost a
comical fiasco the comical element being
trump eating notes and i told you about
this last week
back in 2018 as was reported by newsweek
trump ate a document after cohen meeting
according to former white house aide
omarosa manigault newman she said she
walked in on trump eating paper after a
meeting with lawyer michael cohen
in what she believed was an effort to
destroy sensitive information
i saw him put a note in his mouth since
trump was
why is this story so funny even though
it's so insane since trump was ever the
germaphobe i was shocked he appeared to
be chewing
and swallowing the paper
it must have been something very very
sensitive it is genuinely insane
that the biggest issue of the 2016
election
that trump made about hillary was
document retention policies and this was
what donald trump was doing his entire
presidency and they still have it in for
hillary understand that you know we we
covered trump's rally about
uh
nine days ago
in conroe texas
at that rally he talked about hillary
clinton and the crowd starts chanting
locker up
understand that the origins of locker up
are over hillary's document and email
retention
concerns that donald trump made issue
number one during the 2016 election
they now know or they could know trump
was eating documents trump was ripping
up documents trump was burning documents
trump took documents home to mar-a-lago
and they still can't lock her up about
hillary who has never even been charged
uh never mind convicted of anything
related to that and his supporters will
applaud
they'll applaud lock her up and they'll
applaud trump's illegal activities where
he says well listen we had to we were
just trying to take the election back
from the guy who stole it or whatever
they cheer the corruption
and chant lock her up even though trump
did far worse when it came to records
um and retention of documents
and
handling proper handling of classified
and secret information they still can't
lock her up it's it is a backwards world
that we are living in my friends and the
idea that someday these folks will have
a realization like imagine trump runs in
2024
and we bring up whoever is the
democratic nominee i mean whoever just
brings up hey listen
don't get scammed again by this con man
in 2016 he told you hillary was the
concern when it came to records and
trump ate documents
ripped documents threw him out and had
him burned
he is the con man he was the problem
don't fall for it again it's not going
to work with these people they they will
fall for whatever the 2024 talking point
is as willingly and as readily and as
quickly as they fell for it in 2016 and
that's why the concept of trump 2024
is so scary
follow us on social media interact with
the david pakman show community see
exclusive content see when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
big show announcements we post daily
find us on reddit twitter instagram
facebook discord and tick tock
all right today i have for your
consideration maybe the new most
dishonest fox news graphic of all time
now i'm referring there's a backstory
here a couple months ago um i told you
about a different graphic which at the
time i thought
might be the most dishonest fox news
graphic of all time and it was a graphic
just meant to make joe biden look bad
and it was about the american workforce
and the graphic that fox news put up
compared the trump workforce at its peak
to the biden workforce in october
and it showed that there were three
million fewer people
in the workforce under joe biden in
october
than under trump at the peak
now when you looked at the graphic you
could immediately see it was an
extraordinarily deceptive cherry picking
of data
um
and you could see that they were cherry
picking the dates
showing trump in december of 2019 but
then biden in october of 2021 with no
real rhyme or reason it ignores the
reality of the pandemic it includes the
reality that you can
deceive very easily with labor force
participation because with a growing
population at most times in history the
u.s has had more people working than
ever before and more people not working
than ever before everything about it was
extraordinarily deceptive but
now i have a new graphic that might
actually be even more dishonest and
deceptive
on the dan bongino fox show where
bongino might have just been a guest i
don't know if he was the host here they
put up a graphic called
top 10 most unhealthy u.s cities and the
whole point of this segment is to say
democrats
say they're going to fix problems but
they actually create problems look at
all of these democratic cities and how
unhealthy they are and you look at the
map and they say oh portland maine is
one of the most unhealthy cities in the
u.s and right away you might be thinking
wait what portland maine
why is portland an unhealthy city
seattle washington portland
uh portland oregon that is san francisco
honolulu wait isn't hawaii super healthy
why is hano so
it looked like a weird graphic and they
cite a source and the source is
wallethub so
maybe you think wallethub is reliable
maybe you don't it doesn't matter but
right away we should be asking is this
actually what the wallet hub article
says
and if you go to the story on wallet hub
which we are linking to
you see that their map is actually the
healthiest cities not the least healthy
cities
the healthiest cities
that are identified are the ones that on
the map
fox news says are unhealthy san
francisco
seattle washington portland oregon san
diego california honolulu d.c austin
irvine
portland so you immediately notice first
of all they list irving texas when it's
actually irvine california on the map
and these are the healthiest cities not
the least healthy
um
if you actually
look at the unhealthiest u.s cities
according to this analysis
they are
brownsville texas
laredo texas
gulfport mississippi
shreveport louisiana
memphis tennessee montgomery alabama
fort smith arkansas jackson mississippi
not exactly liberal cities if you look
at the most obese cities in america
which is a factor in health
mcallen texas is the most obese city in
the country memphis baton rouge little
rock shreveport birmingham jackson
mobile
lafayette it is truly pathetic
and this is where i came up with this
acronym caps cap stands for
critically analyzed primary sources so
when you're presented with a graphic
like this
and it says top 10 most unhealthy us
cities
you your first question should be
is this a primary source and of course
it's not the primary source here is
wallet hub so your first step should be
to go and look at wallet hub when you
look at wallet hub if you identify it as
the primary source then you would say
okay
now let me critically analyze this well
what did wallet hub do wallet hub looked
at the 180 most populated u.s cities
they looked at 44 indicators of health
and
these are what they are and then you can
actually say to yourself is this the
right analysis is the analysis done
correctly what's being excluded what's
being included but most importantly does
the data match what fox is giving us and
the answer is of course it doesn't
of course it doesn't it's the opposite
with the additional typo where they put
irving texas on the map
instead of irvine california an absolute
and total humiliation i would argue the
most humiliating
graph or chart
that i've ever seen on fox news if you
have a counterpoint if you have one you
think is more embarrassing or
humiliating uh let me know
i would love to hear it
and uh by the way a couple different dan
bongino stories one he's been kicked off
of youtube for spreading covid this
information and number two
they actually the the bongino people
reached out to me a couple weeks ago
inviting me on
to talk about
some kind of uh book ban thing that i
hadn't heard about uh on a friday night
i wasn't available
should i appear on that show if they
invite me again
i'd be interested in hearing from you i
don't know that they will because i
turned them down
uh but if they invite me again should i
appear with danbongino let me know info
davidpakman.com
sometimes you know when you follow a
story for a while
it's actually rewarding it's actually
rewarding because you can see the
evolution of lies from people and that
is exactly what i have for you today the
headline is we have now learned
republican congressman jim jordan
did talk to donald trump
on the morning of the january 6 trump
riots
for at least 10 minutes straight just
the two of them on the phone
you might say
why is that a story it's a story because
for a year plus now jim jordan has been
deliberately deceptive about his
conversations with donald trump on the
day of the trump riot so let's start
with the news
newly obtained records
show trump and jim jordan spoke at
length on the morning of january 6th
the house select committee investigating
the insurrection now has records which
provide details about a phone call
donald trump made to jim jordan on
january 6th
two sources who reviewed the call
records tell cnn trump spoke on the
phone at the white house residence with
jordan for 10 minutes
on the morning of january 6. why do we
care about that we care about that
because we want to have jim jordan tell
us
what was trump planning what was trump
hoping would happen
on that day and for as long as jim
jordan says oh i don't know i don't know
if i spoke to him before or after
i don't know if i spoke to him at all no
i did but i'm not sure
we can
we have more trouble for to the extent
that we can't prove this conversation
took place
holding jim jordan accountable to get
him to either tell us what trump said on
that day or to say i'm going to plead
the fifth or whatever the case may be a
key focus of the committee's
investigation has been on the run-up to
the insurrection and the myriad ways
trump and his allies including those in
congress
um
uh spoke to trump try to overturn the
election results the new details about
the morning phone call comes as the
committee is debating whether to move
forward with a subpoena for jordan after
he refused to voluntarily appear for an
interview so now we know
that he did speak to him on that morning
here is the
deceiving
constant
back back story with jim jordan first of
all
remember when he spoke to olivier olivia
beavers from politico
where he said quote look i definitely
spoke to the president that day
i don't recall i know it was more than
once i just don't recall the times
he was then asked about it by brett
bayer let's listen to what he had to say
then he's obviously going to go down a
number of different roads uh about who
knew what when who was talking to
coordinators of the protest did you talk
to the former president that day i've
talked to the former president umpteen
times thousands i mean i may not have
been on january
countless times i talk to the president
i never talk about what we talk about so
i just don't think that's appropriate
just like i don't talk about what
happens in republican country now
remember brett bayer didn't ask what you
talked about he said did you talk to him
on that day and jim jordan says i've
talked to him many times
but i don't talk about what we talked
about the question was did you talk to
him on that day
so i've talked to the president numerous
times uh i continue to talk to the
president
on january 6 congressman yes i mean i've
talked to the president
i've talked to the president so many i
can't remember all the days i've talked
to him but i've certainly talked to the
president yeah and and on that day was
can you share any of the insight of what
he was thinking about that day uh brett
the people we need to come testify are
the people who can testify to the
fundamental questions why didn't the
united states capital the people's house
have an appropriate security posture now
what's funny is the committee has
decided jordan should testify but he's
refusing to go that day and what have we
done those are the people we need to
hear from those that's the information
and testimony we need to get
that's what we should focus on but i
don't think that benny thompson the
chairman of this committee said
everything's on the table until we raise
this issue about the speaker's office is
the one who knows what what the security
posture and why it was the way it was
okay so he didn't answer
uh shortly thereafter a couple weeks
later he was then interviewed uh again
and um this was on spectrum news and
just as evasive
there's some confusion over what you
told bret bear on fox news on tuesday
night so i want to clear it up first off
yes or no did you speak with president
trump on january 6th yeah i mean i speak
i spoke with the president last week i
speak with the president all the time i
spoke with him on january 6. i mean i
talk with president trump all the time
and that's that's i don't think that's
so here it was no longer tenable to
maintain he didn't speak to trump on the
6th so so here he conceded i did speak
to him on the 6th unusual uh i would
expect members of congress to talk with
the president of the united states when
they're trying to get done the things
they told the voters in their district
to do
uh i i i'm
actually kind of amazed sometimes if
people keep asking this question of
course i talk to the president
the reason people keep asking is because
he was not directly saying i spoke to
him on january 6th i said i talked with
him last week
on january 6 did you speak with him
before during or after the capital was
attacked
uh i'd have to go i i
i spoke with him that day after i think
after i don't know if i spoke with him
in the morning or not i i just don't
know uh he just doesn't know now it is
completely implausible
that
even if you bought at the time the first
time he was asked did you talk to him
that day
let's give him the benefit of the doubt
because this is how you have to think
about how absurd this was
imagine that jim jordan really speaks to
trump every day
and asked
a month later did you speak to him on
january 6th imagine he genuinely doesn't
remember i don't believe that for a
second i believe you remember but it
let's give him the benefit of the doubt
once it is asked on fox news
and the answer is so obviously deceptive
there is no way in hell
that amongst his
you know plentiful staff
no one comes to him and says sir
you spoke to trump
twice on january 6th including before
the riot so now you know
there is no way after that he doesn't
remember and here he is still saying i
just don't know was it before or after
now of course on a day that's that
momentous it's sort of like if i think
back to 9 11
right i remember where i was and i can
tell you with certainty what happened
after or before like if you say to me
did you work on the on 9 11. i remember
that yes i worked on 9 11. i remember
talking to my colleagues about what was
going on and so if you say and
were you at work at all before the
events took place i can say of course
not there was no period that day where
while at work i learned about what was
happening my entire day at work on 9 11.
i was in high school at the time
was after the events took place when i
went in it was like are we even staying
open this is crazy et cetera there's no
doubt about it because it's a notable
event
and so this idea that oh yeah well did
you speak to him at all before the riot
or
obviously the conversation would either
be what is trump expecting to happen or
what does trump react how is trump
reacting to what is happening
it's just completely implausible that he
doesn't remember i i'd have to go back
and i i mean i don't i don't i don't
know uh though that when when those
conversations happen give me a button um
but what i know is i spoke him all the
time but but taylor the the key here is
the people we need to speak to the
people we need to talk to
are the ones who can answer the question
why wasn't there a better security
presence yeah no jim you're one of the
people that we actually need to be
talking to so
obvious liar obvious liar and now i mean
listen it took what it took 14 months
14 months we've been following this jim
jordan spoke to trump that morning
before the riot
and so jim jordan could tell us
did trump say anything about hoping that
there was violence
did trump say anything about what he was
expecting mike pence to do
this is the guy that we should be
talking to and they try to talk to him
and he's refusing to appear
we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 david p
here is a voicemail that is going to
upset people in my audience because it
is someone saying hey david
as progressives maybe we shouldn't be so
anti-cryptocurrency
uh oh this will this will upset some
people take a listen
hey david this is juvian from
minneapolis i wanted to call and commend
you on your balance stance on crypto and
nfts i'm a progressive and also a crypto
investor and i'm just saddened because i
see like so many progressive thought
leaders demonizing the entirety of
crypto without entertaining like
reasonable discourse on how to properly
regulate it i mean it's all it seems
like they're like trump-like with their
rhetoric sometimes um to me the problem
is like crypto's such a big idea
it's like the internet so like to paint
the entire sector as a ponzi or scam
rises to almost trumpian levels of uh
immaturity
it's not perfect and it needs regulation
but there's a reason this thing
continues to grow and i think there's
like i think it's here to stay and i
feel to see how progressives win by
demonizing it i mean
they might even win like some votes by
helping lead the discussion on
reasonable regulatory policy
yeah listen this is this is really
painful to me that there is such a lack
of balance from many of my friends on
the left on this issue of cryptocurrency
um
it's almost like it's a trigger word you
hear cryptocurrency or you hear the word
bitcoin and it's immediately like no bad
scam illegal crime
right away
um and there's also kind of like a
naivete or maybe an arrogance to think
that
you know the future of this entire space
that you know whether this is something
that's going to be viable or not i think
some humility should tell us we don't
know and that's kind of the whole point
cryptocurrency is clearly here to stay
to some degree
been around more than a decade
major wall street financial advisories
now say to most people
it's not unreasonable to have you know
one to three two to four percent of
assets in cryptocurrency for
diversification it's it's volatile
but it's been around a long time there
are cryptocurrency etfs moving in the
direction of mutual funds
we don't have to like it but the idea
that any second it's going to evaporate
seems increasingly unlikely
now i think the other thing that's
important is
a lot of the bullet points and and again
just as a reminder
i don't care about cryptocurrency any
more than i care about mutual funds or
stocks like
i want to just have
a properly diversified
asset allocation for my risk tolerance
with my money that that's all i care
about
um
sometimes you'll hear well crypto is
mostly being held by wealthy people
right just like the us dollar i mean you
know this this is a systemic problem
money is mostly in the hands of the
wealthy that's not unique to
cryptocurrency so that is that really
the issue not to me
um is crypto used to complete criminal
transactions yeah some i mean apparently
not that much one interesting thing was
when the silk road got shut down it was
believed
that the silk road was basically uh
the the vast majority of bitcoin
transactions and with with the silk road
shut down
um
bitcoin transactions would fall to
almost zero it didn't happen crypto
transactions barely declined when the
the silk road was shut down the dollar
has been used for way more crimes than
bitcoin has it's just a reality it
doesn't tell us one thing or the other
i'm not defending anything
does bitcoin mining not all crypto but
does bitcoin mining have a carbon
footprint absolutely
absolutely and it's impera i mean it's
not going to be sustainable unless
that's dealt with either through
um alternative energy like that's a
that's a problem that's got to be dealt
with
and also
the legacy dollar
and banking industry
has an insane carbon footprint all the
dollars that are brought by tourists to
europe
are then flown back to the us do you
understand the carbon footprint of that
armored cars everywhere insane
infrastructure of banks the overhead
they have private jets i mean it's
if you want to talk about that let's
talk about it but let's also consider
other banking and monetary instruments
in the carbon footprint people hear this
and they go but it's not the same well
just compare one by one and my view on
crypto is nothing is only good
the internet oh my god child porn scams
right but the internet exists and it's
going to exist so we've got to control
the child porn and the scams the stock
market it's rife with scammers fake
financial advisors ponzi schemes yes we
have to deal with that but
investors
investing in the stock market's not
going to end uh you know cars i mean
they
they put out emissions and people die in
car accidents yeah but lis but cars are
going to exist is that we're not at this
point we're not getting rid of cars so
let's make them green let's switch to
electric let's make them safer let's
redesign our roads
i'm not even an evangelist that it
crypto exists it doesn't seem to be
going anywhere
i put a small portion of my assets in
monthly dating back to 2015
and that's it i don't have all my eggs
in there if crypto ends and goes to zero
i lose what is now three to five percent
if it does well then i do it it it's not
something in and of itself that we
should have this
reflexive reaction to
and the problem is that when the left
takes that view
they just miss out on participating in
how to properly regulate crypto and they
leave it to i don't know the
libertarians or whoever let's take a
more balanced view please we've got a
great bonus show for you today sign up
at jointman.com
i will see you then
you